no one loves a trophy more than me I do
I love trophies where are they we need
trophies around they're so cool and our
next guest was awarded one for being the
most improved at basketball camp please
welcome an extraordinary actress writer
director comedian I mean the work so
much so I want to get right into it
Elizabeth babe
[Applause]
you have played so many incredible
interesting characters in different
films and I'm wondering will you play my
favorite game with me yes
[Applause]
okay let's start with The Hunger Games
okay oh gosh all right a fact a tidbit a
morsel I'll fly on the wall moment
anything that comes to you catching fire
uh I wore the butterfly dress which was
actually feathers it was 110 degrees and
Jen Lawrence actually held the fan up
into my dress
that's a sister that's a sister okay
pick perfect oh gosh
you have an entire franchise here of
three films give it to me juicy detail
uh honestly the the thing that comes to
mind randomly is the third film is about
a USO tour because I went on the USO
tour and
um we got the guys to fly their jets in
for like BG and then I went with those
guys and flew in an F-16 no you did not
yeah
so that was pretty fun
you literally ride a rocket like
straight up you did barrel rolls like I
could have full mavericked it
yeah the dream of mine you can make it
happen Drew now people love your pivotal
role on the Beloved iconic show 30 Rock
oh yeah
in the beginning they asked me to be on
two episodes and then I was on it for
like three years so like you play this
woman Avery Jessup yeah do you think
they like what you're putting down
enough well Alec and I got along like a
house on fire so worked out you know
that is what happened on the 30th yeah
I know okay
here we are oh my gosh yeah oh I have a
fun BTS about this oh yeah yeah Mary
steenbergen one of her best friends from
growing up is Bill Clinton
and she brought
she brought Bill and Hillary to the set
of 30 Rock one day no way yes they just
showed up with her it was amazing anyway
okay I had to save this one for last I
mean this is one of the most iconic
films ever made Wet Hot American Summer
yeah
what can I tell you
um we went to a real camp
um to film it so I we all stayed in
bunks oh really you lived on the camera
no together we that's where we were
living we had four dollars to make the
movie so we all lived at Camp Paul Rudd
and Janine Garofalo and David Hyde
Pierce maybe he had like a B and B David
Hyde Pierce was fancy right back then he
was like on Frasier right
um but you know Chris Maloney like
everybody we lived in um dorm rooms and
I had to come back into town for like an
audition or something one day and when I
got back out my entire room was
destroyed they had shot a scene they had
nowhere to shoot it they shot a scene in
what Hot American Summer you can watch
it now where they nurse and Joe would
trulio go around going where is it the
kids we got to get the kids on the
waterfall and they go into a room and
just bash it that was my room it's where
I was living
like they just they were like well she's
not here today
when you and Paul read to that French
kissing scene on the dock like did you
crack up doing it like well you know the
hardest part was a do you know how hard
it is to climb up onto a dock when you
have nothing to put your feet on
there's no ladder on the dock look where
they wanted me to come up is not where
the ladder is so this is a great funny
tidbit that underneath the floating dock
they had to put a person who hung
himself and I stepped in his stomach and
got up onto the dock because I literally
could not get myself with my little tiny
arms could not get myself at the right
level so we're not going to be able to
like do it from here I can't do a
pull-up yeah what am I Superwoman oh my
God yes so that's another one they had
to put a guy under the dock thank you
is that you come out into the world
[Music]